hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome to episode 76 of game
programming so today wouldn't talk about
particles because last time we actually
touched on particles very briefly so if
I actually launch the game and gold away
to our our arm thingy our particle level
thing that we made last episode which
wasn't really particles it's just that
we did cover rendering advanced advanced
rendering of sprites and I drew this
quick thing to kinda let you guys know
what particles would look like it's
right over here by the way from now on
whatever I shoot out is what I'm
actually looking at because the mouse
opponent can be a little hard to see so
if I shoot it something that's generally
what I'm talking about so you can see
I'm treating up this white thing there's
white squares so let's get rid of them
they are in our render method in our um
in our main game Java class I'll just
get rid of all this because that's what
we created and then we won't have it
anymore but I'm not gonna show it that
could all take too long okay so let's
talk about particles how are we gonna do
particles there are many different ways
to do particles but we're going to do
something that is really really simple
and also will get us a really nice
esthetical effect because like when I
think about this the only reason we
probably need particles are for intense
destructions and maybe for environment
effects essentially so that's not really
if you look at Rome on demand God which
is of course the game that we're trying
to clone here they don't really have
many particles at all actually that's a
lie they do have they do have particles
and in fact how particles are gonna look
a lot like this and by that I mean every
time I think you use your spacebar or
whatever I haven't played along with a
mag on like a year by the way so it's
probably changed a lot but um whenever
you I think that the big gods is they're
called they released a lot of particles
when they um I don't know it attack or
something and there's a lot of that
stuff going on so we're gonna talk about
that so what I want to do first is I'm
gonna make an end a new entity subfolder
here so in entity we've got mob
projectile I'm gonna make another one
here a folder called um particle okay
and this will basically just have all of
our particles in there because we will
have kind of like projectiles we'll have
a are like a master classes as
the class and then we'll have subclasses
so we'll make a new class in this
particle folder and we'll call the
particle pretty pretty straightforward
and a particle is gonna have a bunch of
a bunch of random things if we actually
look at our entity class lots of this
entity class our entity class you can
see that we've got around them we've got
an instance of the random class that we
can use throughout our code so one thing
we need to do is make sure that particle
extends entity and the reason we wanted
to do that is because of course we want
to add particles to our level to our
level and the way we do that it through
is through entities I'm sure I don't
need to remind you but we've got an
array list of entities called entities
in our level class and in order to rent
projectiles we want to kind of add it to
this list so noted for us to be able to
do that it needs to extend entity and
also more or less we wanted to have
these same traits so we wanted to have
an X Y position that's where they
originate that's not where they're gonna
stay because of course particles will
come first out whether we also have be
removed we want them to have a level and
well I mean we will not update then we
want to render them and we want to do
everything here so there it makes sense
that they are an entity I'm just making
myself clear here so let's let's do this
what I like to do is typically create an
ArrayList inside of this class so we'll
create a private list called particle
and we'll full of particles it was new
ArrayList particle okay not gonna show
up for us and let's import java.util
list the reason I do this is because
it's it's quite rare for us to make
particles by themselves okay we'll
usually create 10 or 20 or a hundred
particles straight away okay it's very
red that will be like yeah let's just
pop out one single particle and because
of that instead of having to manage this
creation of multiple particles on the in
the place that we call these particles
we can just do that
straightaway inside this thing and that
would be actually made Mac up make a
card a lot cleaner so what what we want
to do here is create a constructor and
of course this constructors basically
just going to take probably four
parameters so the web the X and y
position of where the particles are
going to originate from the life so how
long they're going to last well because
it because of course you want particles
to disappear after a while otherwise um
they said they're forever well you're
gonna keep rendering them forever
and that'll slow your game down a lot
and then also we just don't want them to
be there forever like it's just like an
aesthetical thing we want them to
disappear after a while and then we'll
create another integer here called the
mount and that's how many particles we
want this is like this particle thing to
actually generate so one thing that we
can do first of all is if we check out
our sprite class I'm not sure if we made
a pipe okay we need to make a particle
so let's make a ultimately particles
thing here particles can typically be
made within code because they're not
usually um you know they're not usually
images of something so we'll call it
particle underscore you know normal I
guess and we'll create a new sprite and
we'll just use this sum in size and
color constructor because we want them
to be square and we want them to be just
a color based way
so let's um let's make them what size
let's make him three for now we'll see
if this might be too big we'll see and
the color I'll just make them I'll just
make them pretty light gray so 6a is
okay all right cool so now that we've
got sprite called particle normal we can
actually set in our particle here we can
set the sprite equal to particle normal
now you might be like what's going on
what if I want to set my sprite to
something else or what if I want each
individual particle to have different
things oh we don't have this why doesn't
okay and she should really have sprites
trimmed a what's going on here
did I don't say entity should have
sprites okay well we'll make us fried
here for now but I think I might change
that later
okay so again that's what I mentioned
earlier is that will you know how we
have a different wizard projector we
have different chef projectiles we have
subclasses of this projectile cloth same
thing here right if you want to specific
if you want a specific particle you just
you know just suppose just just make a
subclass that whose parent is particle
and you do whatever you want so we'll
also make all these global variables
here for armed for this stuff so we
don't need X&Y obviously that's in the
entity class we do need life so that's
an integer and amount we don't need
either because you'll see why in a
minute so we'll make life and we'll also
make a bunch of I'm not gonna get into
the math of this now just because I'm
you know this video is gonna be quite
long if I do that but what we also need
to do is create some more variables
which I'll do in the next video to
actually handle this
basically the animation of these
particles since we want them to kind of
bounce and you know do all that cool
stuff so what else should we do right so
let's set up this array list quickly
we've set the sprite oh we make sure you
said this dot X equal to X is start Y
into y I'll probably be the first thing
I do just because it looks better and
we'll set this dot live people to life
now what will we do with the amount what
we want to do is we want to set up this
particle as much as we have as much as
we can okay and you can see that we've
sort of done this now because we've done
this because we've done this we can it's
it's it's kind of important for us to do
this before we add it into the ArrayList
because if we add it to the ArrayList
and then modify it well the copy you
know this isn't like this isn't say your
c c c++ or any else a shot and I shall
Ivan I'll use just shout that much but
the point is there are other places
funny isn't it because
I can make a joke out of this the point
is there are no pointers say that humor
that's uh anyway um so pointers their
honor there aren't any pointers in Java
so in other words once we added to the
ArrayList that's it if we modified after
that you know we're not creating a
pointer to that client to that object so
therefore whatever we do afterwards
isn't going to be you know the one
that's in the array list so it's gonna
be useless to us so what we want to do
is we want to do everything and then add
it into the array list so there's a few
different way that we could do this but
the way I'm actually gonna do this is
more of a universal method so if we make
another constructor here in particle and
this will be the same but it won't have
an amount so this can be used right this
can be used if we only make if we only
want to make one particle but it can
also be used if we want to make multiple
particles it's just that this will have
to be called repeatedly that's how we're
going to do this so what I'm going to do
is I'm actually going to cut all this
and put this into here right and over
here what I want to do is after we've
set all of our properties here so we've
said this at life equal to life we've
set our X&Y positions and we have set
sprite to what we wanted to be I'm
actually just gonna go particles dot add
this okay and what that's going to do is
it's gonna take this instance of this
class with all of these properties that
we've set and it's gonna add that into
this ArrayList okay now that's great
okay that's exactly what we want to do
and but that only does that once what if
we have multiple things to do it with
that's fine because what we can do is
first of all create a particle here so I
can call this XY life right so what I'm
doing here is I'm running this
constructor and that will actually add
one into it but that's not that's not
all I want to do I actually want to run
a full loop up it is and we're gonna
have to do this first one that's just oh
I'll show you what I mean in a minute so
eyes less than amount will say I plus
plus in fact we'll just go on mount
minus one
we'll go particles dot add a new
particle XY and life now let me explain
this real quick because this might be a
bit confusing for you guys what this is
doing when I pulled this when I called
the this keyword in Java in this context
what it means is I'm actually just
referring if we control click on this
you can see that it actually points to
this particle constructor what I'm doing
is I'm calling another constructor so
what I'm not making another another
instance of this particle class that's
really important that you realize this
all I'm doing is simply calling the code
in here as if it was any other method so
what I could do just to show you guys is
create particle could be here and then I
could make a private void called create
particle and paste all this code into
here and basically well you know for the
context of this and we'll do this and
smile life and then I could just replace
this with this right
so I'll replace this with create
particle and that achieves the same
effect okay but again it has this extra
method it doesn't really need to be here
so it's kind of not really clean to me I
prefer just to do it this way ok so
that's exactly what it does it treats
the constructor as any other method and
it simply execute the code inside it
once it's done that and the reason I do
this is because if we actually do run
particles on add we're basically
discarding this instance we're not using
it and that's kind of a waste right we
want to you know since we've created
this instance which runs this we don't
want to make new instances we might as
well add the particle that we've already
made because of course we've made an
instance of a particle in order to add
particles to this particles array so
that's that's another confusing concept
but if you read this code I'm sure
you'll understand I'll try to explain
this in as much detail as possible and
the other thing that we've done here is
of course what we need to do since we've
read this instance is set everything now
instead of copying and pasting this code
into this constructor I can simply call
it using this is much cleaner and then
what I'll do is I'll
and since we've already added one
particle into this because if we called
this you'll say that it does go
particles don't add this so it's added
it's already added this instance into
itself into this particle array so
there's no point you know that'll work
that's all better that already counts as
one particle so in this in this it is
four in this four loop here where we
actually add all about all the rest of
the particles we should add minus one
because we've already added this one
otherwise you know we'll get one more
than what we wanted so if we put one for
the amount essentially we'll get two
particles because we're doing at once
here and then once here okay so this for
loop again will simply generate this
amount minus one new particles and add
them into this array so that everything
can function as it should so just
quickly I'm just going to make basically
I'm just going to override entities
methods here we have render we have
update I'm simply going to override them
by typing public well update update will
contain all of our animation code that
we'll cover in the next episode and
public void render using our renderer
which is render render well of course
it's import
will of course no it's called screen my
bad
screen actually what are we exactly call
it screen screen okay there you go and
screen is of course our renderer which
will render our code what if we want to
render these particles to the screen so
we'll cover updating so in other words
animating our particles and the math
behind that and actually rendering them
to the screen in the next video so I
hope you enjoyed this webisode of grant
Afghan but I've gained there a lot of
game programming got economics speak I'm
so tired I just basically got off um my
last lecture today I finished at 7:20
p.m. so I've been at uni like all day so
I'm really tired and I haven't got much
sleep because a lot I'm daring because
of other work that I've had to do it's
just ridiculous but um I'm sorry that
these episodes have been so infrequent
I'll try and make the move it a bit more
frequent but I just have quite a lot of
work to do but other than that I should
watch a program I'm gonna come back
don't worry about that every time I take
like a week off you guys like please
don't ditch this project you know please
have you finished this already we want
more episodes no I haven't finished any
any of the series that I've started on
my channel have not finished yet and
they will in one point in time okay as
long as I'm alive so you can count on
that
okay so if you like this video please
hit the like button it really makes me
wanted to make more videos and I'll see
you guys next time goodbye
you